[Music]
stage one is trans Sonic Landing
Lakeside deployed
and Falcon 9 has landed
hello everyone my name is Krista Rhodes
I am a structures engineer here at
SpaceX I'll be your host for today's
starlink Mission which marks spacex's
29th launch of the year and 228th
overall mission to date on your screen
is a live view of our Falcon 9 rocket on
space launch complex 40 in Florida
awaiting liftoff at 3 31 a.m Eastern
Time
at T minus 4 minutes and 44 seconds the
range is green and ready to support and
weather is looking good the teams are
currently tracking no issues with the
vehicle or spacecraft
and we should be seeing these strong
back clamp arms opening up shortly
in about 15 seconds round by retract has
started
and as you can see on your screen the
clamp arms are now beginning to open up
beneath the second stage after they open
up fully you'll see the strong backs
start moving away from the vehicle in
preparation for takeoff
foreign
back also referred to as the te or
transporter erector is the large
structure that you see next to Falcon 9.
we use it to raise it to its vertical
launch position and Route power
umbilicals and Telemetry to the vehicle
and payload before they're ready to go
on their own internal power
[Music]
and coming up next at T minus three
minutes we should hear that stage one
has completed liquid oxygen loading
[Music]
who we can expect stage one liquid
oxygen loading to conclude simply
at T minus three minutes Falcon 9's
first stage is now fully loaded with rp1
and liquid oxygen and we're now awaiting
completion of walks loading on the
second stage in about 50 seconds
and the white clouds that you see
circling around the vehicle are
completely nominal and they're the
result of our super chill liquid oxygen
coming into contact with relatively warm
Ambient Air at the launch site turning
the liquid oxygen back to its gaseous
state
and again we're currently waiting for
stage two lock slope completion which
should conclude at T minus two minutes
stage two locks look complete and with
that call out Falcon 9 is now fully
loaded with 1 million pounds of fuel and
liquid oxygen
the booster or first stage of the rocket
you see on your screen is flying for its
seventh time today having previously
supported crs-24
util snap pop for 13f one web one SCS 18
to 19 and two star Leaf missions
[Applause]
after liftoff and Stage separation this
booster will land on our drone chip a
shortfall of gravitop
[Music]
and as you just heard the call out
Falcon 9 is now in startup meaning that
the flight computers have now taken over
the launch countdown
in just a few seconds we should hear our
launch director or LD give the final go
for launch
LD go for launch
and the launch director has given the
final go to proceed for launch let's sit
back and watch as Falcon 9 takes our 56
Starling satellites into space
T-minus 30 seconds
foreign
[Applause]
Vehicles pitching down range
[Music]
thank you
at t plus 30 seconds Falcon 9 has
successfully lifted off from space
launch complex 40 at Cape Canaveral
Florida in at 3 31 a.m Pacific Eastern
Time
the next major Milestone coming up is
Max Q which is one of the vehicle
experiences the greatest amount of
external sources as it descends through
the Earth's atmosphere during its flight
today
my detail pressures
Falcon 9 to supersonic
Falcon 9 is now supersonic meaning it is
traveling faster than the speed of sound
and coming up next we will be hearing a
call out for Max Q
Max Q
and there was the call out for Max Q
which again is when the vehicle
experiences its largest amount of
external stresses
[Music]
we are about one minute away from a
series of events being Mikko stage
separation scs-1 and then fairing
separation
Rico stands for main engine cutoff which
is when all nine Merlin engines will
shut down in preparation for stage
separation during stage separation the
first and second stages will separate
from each other the first stage will
begin its Journey back to Earth while
the second stage will light its Merlin
vacuum engine to propel our Starling
satellites to their planned orbits let's
keep an eye out for these events
happening in pretty quick succession
and you can expect those to start in
about 20 seconds
stage separation confirmed
and vacation
and as you just saw and heard over the
Nets we had successful Mikko stage step
and scs-1 we're now coming up on fairing
separation for the second from the
second stage just a few seconds faring
separation confirmed
faring separation has been confirmed we
will be attempting to recover both
bearing halves using our recovery vessel
Bob both of the fairing halves that
supported today's Mission are flight
proven with one half flying for its
eighth time and the other half flying
for its ninth time
both the first and second stages are
following nominal trajectories and
currently the first stage is on its way
back to Earth towards our drone ship a
shortfall of Gravitas and our mvac
engine as you can see on your screen is
attached to our second stage and
continuing its burn which will last
around another four minutes
and although we don't have views of the
first stage right now vehicle is still
healthy and successfully making its way
back to our Landing site
acquisition a signal Bermuda
and as a reminder starlink is a
satellite internet constellation
designed and manufactured by SpaceX to
provide high-speed low latency internet
to people living in remote and Rural
locations all around the globe
and as an update for our first stage it
is still performing nominally and still
making its way back to our Landing site
and a successful return of this booster
vehicles on a nominal trajectory
a successful return of this booster
again will Mark spacex's 189th Landing
to date
and as I mentioned earlier today's
starlink Mission Mark spacex's 228th
Mission overall and the 29th Mission
just this year and coming up next in
this mission is entry burn on the first
stage which will which is the first of
two Burns it will go through in
preparation for landing
and we can begin expect that entry burn
to begin at t plus six minutes
stage one FTS has saved
page one is your brand startup
and there's a call out for stage one
entry burn stage one which we also call
the booster has ignited engines numbers
one five and nine to slow it down for
atmospheric re-entry
and now we finally have first stage
views and it's currently making its way
back to our Landing site
stage two FTS has saved
you just heard the call up the entry
burn on the first stage has completed
and coming up next is our Landing burn
on the first stage which will be the
second and final burn in preparation for
landing
and stage one has one more burn left to
land on our drone trip a shortfall of
Gravitas
meanwhile our second stage is still
continuing its first burn and performing
nominally
both vehicles on a nominal victory
we can expect our Landing burn to begin
around t plus eight minutes
stage one transonic
and once that burn begins it's going to
last around 20 seconds
and there's confirmation that these
stage when Landing burn has started in
preparation for a touchdown on our drone
ship a shortfall of Gravitas
deploy
th1 lighting is confirmed
and this Falcon 9 first stage has now
successfully launched and landed
we are now coming up on second engine
cutoff
expect a lot signal cable
and back shut down
and there you heard the call out we were
waiting for Seco one and
nominal orbit insertion
we now have been able to confirm both
Seco one and nominal orbital insertion
and confirmation of a good orbit for our
56 Starling satellites today's Landing
marks our 189th overall Landing of an
orbital class rocket including Falcon 9
and Falcon heavy missions with
confirmation of successful first stage
landing and second engine cutoff that
will wrap up our coverage for today
be sure to check our social media for
confirmation of starlink deployment and
thank you so much for watching and we
will see you next time
[Music]
foreign